hey guys it's alex so as we all know
it's been a bit of an off year
but if there's been one shining star
it's banana bread there's been this
comeback of banana bread online i see
so many people making it at home and
that's amazing because it's one of my
favorite things to make
and to eat so i was talking to my friend
reggie and he actually told me that he
had
never had banana bread before i don't
even know how he's gotten through this
year without it
so i've asked reggie to make the
simplest form of banana bread out there
and i am gonna make the more elevated
version
they say less is more but when it comes
to banana bread
i'm betting more is more so you told me
that you have never had banana bread is
this
true yes yes unfortunately i have never
had banana bread i know you don't cook
that often which is why
i'm taking the elevated recipe and i'm
giving you
the simple version is that okay with you
that works perfectly for me
keep the training wheels on training
wheels are very much on
and i hope you'll fall in love with
banana bread like i've always
i mean there's only there's only one way
to find out
you owe me a banana bread all right it
is time to get started on our five
hour banana bread cause it's gonna take
all day
so first things first i am going to
roast our bananas i am using
these yellow bananas because this way
those sugars will really
caramelize and you're gonna get a lot of
flavor out of the banana so next i'm
gonna get started on our chai
infused whipped cream now i'm not even
gonna use this until the
end but it does need two whole hours to
infuse
so better get it done right now so i'm
just gonna cut open two
chai tea bags and pop them into some
heavy whipped cream
and let this sit at room temperature to
infuse after those two hours i'm gonna
pop it in the fridge to chill for
another two hours
that's why you wanna do this first next
i'm gonna make the candied walnuts that
go into
the banana bread batter super
straightforward just toast your walnuts
melt down your sugar until it's amber
color and then mix it all together i'm
going to spread it out on a baking sheet
as the walnuts cool the sugar will
harden into a candy shell
once they're cooled chop them up and set
them aside
okay we're making progress for our last
step before
the actual banana bread batter i'm gonna
make a banana
foster's sauce to go on the bottom of
the pan melt your butter over medium
heat and add in your brown sugar
cinnamon and vanilla and mix it all up
until it's nice and melted down
now we're gonna get a little fancy i'm
gonna flambe this sauce which means i'm
adding a little dark rum
this will catch on fire and i'm gonna
let it burn for a couple of minutes
until all that alcohol is cooked off
once the alcohol cooks off the flame
will go out if you do do this at home
please
please please be very very careful now
i'm gonna pour our delicious sauce into
a greased
loaf pan i'm gonna press one slice
banana
into the sauce and then pop this in the
fridge for 40 minutes to cool
okay it's hard to believe that i haven't
even started making
the bread yet but we are finally here
never thought i'd get here honestly
first i'm gonna mix up the dry
ingredients and set them aside
next i'm gonna take those bananas we
roasted in the beginning and mix them up
with a hand mixture
until they're nice and smooth to the
bananas i'm adding three eggs one at a
time and mixing them fully in between
each addition
so now i'm going to keep mixing and
gradually add in my dry
mixture just be careful not to over mix
here next i'm gonna fold in our candied
walnuts and some chopped dark chocolate
i'm gonna scoop this batter right on top
of our prepared
loaf pan with that banana foster sauce
on the bottom and pop it in the oven at
250 degrees fahrenheit for two
hours so we're actually slow baking this
banana bread at a low temperature
so that all those flavors really come
out of the bread while baking
now we wait maybe now is a good time to
take a little nap
five minute banana bread mug cake
recipe first things first get my over
ripe banana
and mash it until it's a haste
consistency
next i'm gonna add in my egg my flour
baking powder
my brown sugar my vanilla extract and
cinnamon and
whisk it together until everything's
mixed in and looking good
after that i'm gonna fold in my
chocolate chips next you're gonna spray
down a microwave-safe mug
pour in your mixture and pop it in the
microwave for two minutes
once i take it out i'm gonna garnish it
with a couple of banana slices
some chocolate chips and bada boom
bada-bing you've got five-minute banana
bread let's see how alex is doing
oh our banana bread is finally ready so
now i'm gonna gently flip our loaf
onto a plate and let all that delicious
banana foster sauce pour
down all over the sides so while our
banana bread is cooling i'm just gonna
finish up this delicious chai infused
whipped cream
i'm gonna strain out those chai leaves
whip it until it thickens
add a little sugar to sweeten it up and
keep whipping until medium peaks form
it is time to eat this thing but you
know what after five hours if there's
one thing i do want to eat
it's banana bread all right reggie how
did it go
it was a breeze i mean it only took five
minutes i told you well this
is my first bite of this okay let's go
oh i think mine's the winner
how can you you didn't even taste mine i
will say it definitely looks better than
mine but for the lover of banana bread
you can make yours every single day no
problem
you're not wrong about that to banana
bread two banana bread
cheers cheers
see you later bye well there you have it
whether you like your banana bread
simple or
a little more complex i think reggie and
i both agree
that banana bread is always delicious
let us know which one
you would prefer to make and if you have
your own take give me all the banana
bread recipes this is what i need to say
see you guys next time
[Music]
you